now the european union and british
swedish drug maker astrazeneca have
failed to make a breakthrough in a
dispute over supply shortages of cobit
19 vaccine to the block
the company said in a statement that it
had a constructive conversation with the
eu
about scaling up production astrazeneca
had sparked anger by saying
it would deliver 60 fewer doses of the
vaccine than promised
in the first quarter of this year now
rollout of the vaccine has been slower
than expected across the european union
and here in germany frustration is
growing
accessing this vaccination center in
brandenburg in eastern germany
is harder than it might look to get an
appointment for a covid19 jab
you need staying power only those
determined enough to get past the
overloaded hotline will get an
appointment
like manfred and herter grunberg both
are over 80 and belong to germany's
number one high-risk group
our daughter got the appointment for us
but it took her a long time to get
through and arrange the time
as in other vaccination centers in
germany things are moving slowly
many booths remain empty because there's
not enough vaccine
only 70 people a day can be immunized
instead of the planned 600.
the situation is even worse in other
regions
this center in cologne is not even open
appointments are being made for february
but it's not an easy process
i'm not just calling them to be kept on
hold for hours and then you don't even
get an appointment
my appointment was made online by my son
right on the first day
in the morning the hotline in
northriver's failure is overwhelmed
other countries are moving faster israel
for example has already vaccinated
almost half its population
about 4 million people britain has
immunized 10 percent
the us-7 germany has vaccinated around 2
million people
2 percent of the population in line with
many other countries
germany's social democrats say that's
not good enough
yeti israel britain and the us
are all making progress but there are a
lot of problems in the european union
and we need to address them quickly
vaccine manufacturers contracted to
supply eu member states are now
reporting production delays
not good news for this facility in
brandenburg or
others around germany filling these
chairs
is likely to take some time
let's get more on the story with our
political correspondent thomas sparrow
hi thomas
as we saw there germany is lagging
behind other countries when it comes to
vaccinating
is it clear at this point why that is
there are certain elements to me that
can help explain
why that is but first you obviously have
to understand how the process works
because it's a very complex process
altogether
it's sometimes forgotten that the
procurement of the vaccine does not
happen
at a local or a national level it is
actually
coordinated by the european commission
then distributed
to each european union member country
depending on the number of
of inhabitants and then each country so
in this case germany
distributes then the vaccine to the
different states and the different
states are then in charge
of carrying out the process of making
the appointments as we saw for example
in the report
and in all of those stages throughout
the process
there has been problems if you look
specifically at what has happened here
in germany
there have been logistical problems
there have been individual oversights as
well some of the states have complained
that the distribution is too slow that
they're not getting
enough vaccines but this obviously is
something that also has to do with the
fact that at a european level
there is this vaccine shortage so there
are different ways to understand
this problem but it is clear that it's
not only a sign of hope
as it was presented by the german
government as it was presented by german
officials
it's also definitely becoming a big
headache for german officials and one
that they want to make sure
that they resolve soon what about
another headache this dispute between
the european union and
astrazeneca how is that affecting
germany
it is certainly a big headache but again
it's important to understand
this from a broader perspective it's not
something that
only affects germany because the
procurement is being done at a european
union level that means that the
discussions are not being carried out by
one member country with the
pharmaceutical company
but by the european commission with the
respective pharmaceutical company
the problem is that the european union
had put a lot of hope
when it comes to the astrazeneca vaccine
and the member countries obviously as
well
because it has been reported that the
vaccine is cheaper that it's easier to
store
so basically they were hoping that this
vaccine alongside the others that have
already been approved could actually
help
to reduce that shortage that is being
discussed all across the continent
and here in germany what are authorities
doing to improve the situation
the social democrats for example we saw
that in our report are calling for a
clearer
plan they're calling for better
communication for example between
federal and state authorities and this
is something that
may well be discussed in the next few
days the social democrats called for
example for a so-called
vaccination summit and in fact we just
heard now from the
health minister the german health
minister yen span that they may well be
this vaccination summit because germany
according to him still has
around 10 more weeks of vaccination
shortage so there is clearly a lot of
pressure for authorities
to try and find out a what the problem
is and b
how they can tackle this problem
appropriately our political
correspondent thomas sparrow thank you
for bringing us up to date
now another country suffering because of
a shortage of vaccine in europe
is serbia the country's president
recently compared the situation to the
sinking
of the titanic as rich nations tried to
save themselves at the expense of poor
ones
even so serbia has managed to launch a
mass vaccination drive for its people
but it has done so not with the help of
the eu but with the help
of china
even during the pandemic customers still
come in for their coffee
oyan jojovic has run this cafe in
belgrade for three years
a topic often discussed by patrons is
which vaccine is the best
u.s company pfizer and russia have so
far only delivered a few thousand doses
china has already sent a million
would i choose to get the chinese
vaccine chinese people have been getting
it
they wouldn't be harming their own
people maybe i'll take
pfizer's vaccine they are an
economically strong company
it's a bit of a dilemma for me
serbia's government has promised to buy
various vaccines from providers all over
the world
it's then up to citizens to decide which
one they want to get
i'll get the chinese or russian vaccine
not the fisa one
if i had to choose i'd take the russian
one
the russian one i like russia i have
russian friends
i trust them who to trust
there's a lack of detailed information
about the various vaccines
that's why many serbian doctors are
hesitant with their advice
i get at least 10 calls a day people
asking whether they should get
vaccinated
and if so using which vaccine
we only have information on the pfizer
vaccine
i just don't know enough about the other
ones
no one seems sure but plenty of people
are driven by their fear of getting sick
older citizens can receive the vaccine
at a total of 200 special
sites like at this exhibition center in
belgrade
serbia purchased 8 million vaccines from
western supplies from russia
and china but only china can deliver
millions of doses of covet-19 vaccines
in a short period of time
so china's reputation on the balkan is
on the rise
in the meantime boyan georgeovich has
made his decision
many of my customers who come here know
more than i do about
vaccines now i have decided to get the
chinese one
like many serbians they take the
pragmatic view that the best vaccine
is the most available one and here china
seems to have won the race
here's a look now at some other
developments in the pandemic portugal
will suspend all flights
to and from brazil beginning friday
that's due to the new strain of the
coronavirus circulating there
vietnam has reported its first community
transmission of the virus in almost
eight weeks
the country has had strict quarantine
measures throughout the pandemic
and the khan film festival has been
moved from may
to july in the hopes of being able to
hold the event on the french riviera
in person